Now that we have finished going through the custom body workflow and have all of the modified
assets for Atomic Savage, we are now ready to bring them into Unreal Engine and finalize
the rig.
We will dive into a hands-on exercise where we will bring the head LOD-FBX files and final
metahuman-DNA file into Unreal Engine and configure the metahuman blueprint and assign
the custom body.
We will also go over how to import the custom body into Unreal Engine and test the customized
face and body with animations to make sure everything is working correctly.
So let's dive into the hands-on exercise and start finalizing this custom metahuman
character.
In this section, we will go through a hands-on exercise.
We will primarily work in Unreal Engine to bring in the head LODs, the calibrated metahuman-DNA
file, we will configure the metahuman blueprint and assign the custom body.
As we work through this exercise, you will note that this is broken down into a step-by-step
process that is found in your slide deck.
As we complete portions of the practical exercise, I will review the completed steps.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine and begin to finalize our customized metahuman character.
Inside of Unreal Engine, we will begin to bring in our modified metahuman assets.
Let's get started by first duplicating the metahuman face skeletal mesh that we will
be updating.
I'm going to select Atomic Savage in our level.
This metahuman is named Atomic Savage Example.
To locate this character's face mesh, I'm going to go to the Details panel and locate
the head component and select it.
Then I can go to the face skeletal mesh and use the folder to browse to its location.
Now I'm going to right-click on the face skeletal mesh and select Duplicate.
We will need this copy later on when we reassign the grooms in the metahuman blueprint.
Now I'm going to save this.
And now I'm going to select the original skeletal mesh and double-click on it to open
it.
With this window open, the first step is to assign a source file path in order to re-import
the head LOD FBX files.
In the Asset Details panel, I will search for File.
What we want to locate is the Import Settings.
In the Asset Import Data File Path, we want to set the source file path for the FBX files.
I will click on this and this will open up the Exports folder and I'm going to select
LOD 0 and then select Open.
The next step is to re-import the head LODs as new files.
Now it is worth mentioning that users may encounter issues when re-importing the FBX
in the current 5.5 engine version.
So to work around this, in the command Prompt, I will paste the command interchange.featureflag.import.fbx
with the value set to 0 and hit Enter.
I will save everything and now I'm going to go up here to the Re-import Mesh with Dialog
drop-down and select Re-import Mesh with new file.
This will open up the Exports folder, I will select LOD 0 and select Open and the FBX
import options will appear.
Here I want to make sure that the face archetype is assigned as a skeleton.
In the Transform section, I will change the import rotation to 90 degrees since the head
FBX is in Y up and then select Import.
This may take a moment.
Now we have the head LOD 0 imported.
It may look strange at first and that is because we have to update the metahumanDNA file.
I'm going to save this.
Now we still need to re-import the other head LODs so I will clear my search in the Asset
Details panel and locate the LOD Settings section.
To re-import the lower LODs, I will go to the LOD import and drop this down.
I will select Re-import LOD Level 1 and then select the LOD 1 FBX and select Open.
And once the import process is complete, a notification will appear.
You can repeat this for all of the LODs if you wish.
If you are going to be working with LOD 0 only, ensure that you set the forced LOD to
0 in the metahuman blueprint and I've already done that for this character.
Now let's do a quick review of the steps we just went through before we move on.
In order to bring in the modified metahuman assets, to get started we will want to duplicate
the face skeletal mesh of the metahuman whose assets we will be updating.
To do this, locate the face skeletal mesh in the face folder of the metahuman characters
folder.
Then select the skeletal mesh, right click on it and select Duplicate.
This duplicate of the head skeletal mesh will be used when reassigning the groom binding
assets.
Once that is complete, the first step is to assign a source file path in order to re-import
the head LOD FBX files.
To assign a source file path, open up the face skeletal mesh and go to the Asset Details
panel.
In the Import Settings section, for the Asset Import Data file path, direct it to the folder
where the head LOD FBX files are located and then select the LOD0 FBX file.
The next step is to re-import the head LOD FBX as new files.
As mentioned, users may encounter issues when re-importing the head LOD FBX files in the
current 5.5 engine version.
To work around this, in the command Prompt, enter the Interchange Feature Flag Import
FBX command and set the value to 0 and hit Enter.
To re-import an LOD with a new file, go to the Re-import Mesh with Dialog option in the
toolbar and select Re-import Mesh with New File.
For the FBX import options, ensure that the face archetype skeleton is selected and then
select Import.
The head LOD0 will be re-imported and it may not look correct at first, but that is normal
as the DNA file has not been updated yet.
The next step is to re-import the lower LODs.
To re-import the lower LODs, in the Face Skeletal Mesh Asset, in the Asset Details panel, locate
the LOD Settings section.
Then in the LOD Import option, use the drop-down arrow to re-import each LOD.
As mentioned, if you intend to use LOD0 only and do not wish to re-import the lower LODs,
ensure that you change the forced LOD to 0 in the Metahuman Blueprint LOD Sync Component
Settings.
With the head LODs re-imported, the next step is to update the Metahuman DNA file.
So let's return to Unreal Engine and continue with the steps.
Back inside of Unreal Engine, let's navigate back to the main viewport.
We will see that the grooms on the Metahuman do not look correct, and we will fix that
in a moment.
What we want to do for the next step is to import the new DNA file.
To update the Metahuman DNA file, in the Content Browser, I'm going to select the original
Face Skeletal Mesh and right-click on it.
Over here I'm going to select Metahuman DNA and select Import New DNA File.
I'm going to navigate to the Exports folder, which is inside of my DNA calibration folder
in the Working folder, and then inside of the Export folder, I will select the Atomic
S Final DNA, and then select Open.
The DNA Import Options will open, and we just want to ensure that the correct Face Skeletal
Mesh is selected, and then we can select Import.
I'm going to save everything.
Now before we move on, let's review the steps we just covered.
To import the new Metahuman DNA file, select the Face Skeletal Mesh and right-click on
it.
Then select Metahuman DNA and choose Import New DNA File.
Locate and select the DNA file that has been updated, and select Open.
For the DNA Import Options, ensure that the Face Skeletal Mesh is assigned, and then select
Import.
Now let's return to Unreal Engine and continue with the next steps of this exercise.
Back inside of Unreal Engine, we have just finished updating the Metahuman DNA.
As we can see in the viewport, the grooms do not look correct, and that is because we
need to reassign the groom assets.
To do this, we will first select the duplicated skeletal mesh.
Then we want to open up the Metahuman Blueprint for our character.
We can do this by selecting the Metahuman in the viewport, and next to its name in the
Outliner, we can click on Edit Blueprint.
This will open up the Metahuman Blueprint for our character.
I will navigate to the viewport.
Now we want to re-bind all of the grooms, so I will select the eyelashes component first.
In the Details panel, I will navigate to the groom binding asset over here and open it.
With the duplicated face mesh still selected in the Content Browser, I'm going to assign
it here using this arrow as the source skeletal mesh.
I'm going to save this and close it.
We will have to repeat this for all of the grooms.
I will select the Peach Fuzz component.
Then in the Details panel, I will open up the groom binding asset and use the arrow
to assign the duplicated face mesh as the source skeletal mesh.
I will save this and close it.
I will repeat this for the eyebrows component.
Select it.
Open up the groom binding and assign the duplicated face mesh as the source skeletal mesh.
Save this and close it.
For the hair component, again, I will select it.
Then open up the groom binding asset and assign the duplicated face mesh as the original
skeletal mesh.
Now, this one will take a bit longer to process.
Once it is done, I will save this and close it.
And finally, we have the beard component.
I will select it.
Open up the groom binding asset and assign the duplicated face mesh.
Then save it and close it.
What you will notice is that the grooms look correct now.
However, the neck region does not.
And the reason for this is that the head and updated joint positions are constrained to
the original body so the skeletons are not aligned.
So the next step is to assign the custom body.
Now I've already imported the custom body into this project and will go over the steps
on how I imported it later on.
For now, let's go back to the main viewport.
In the content browser, we are going to locate the custom body.
In our course assets folder, there is a folder named AtomicSBody.
Inside of here, the skeletal mesh for the custom body is located here and it is named
AtomicSBodyExportSkinweights.
With this selected, we are going to go back to the metahuman blueprint.
Next select the body component and in the details panel, in the skeletal mesh section,
I'm going to use the arrow to assign the custom body.
We can see the skeletons are now aligned.
We can compile and save this.
And if we go back to our main viewport, we will see our finalized metahuman character.
Now let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
Once we have re-imported the head LODs and updated the metahuman DNA, the next step is
to re-bind the grooms.
To do this, inside of the metahuman blueprint, select each of the groom components, then
open up the groom binding asset, assign the duplicated face mesh as the source skeletal
mesh, and then compile and save.
To assign a custom body, in the metahuman blueprint, select the body component, then
in the details panel, assign the body skeletal mesh to the skeletal mesh asset, then compile
and save.
Now we just went through the steps of finalizing the customizations of our metahuman character.
For the hands-on exercise, I had already imported the custom body.
In the next section, I will go over the steps of how to import the custom body and configure
it so that it behaves correctly when it is assigned to the body component.